Donald Trump has been indicted again and
you're gonna love this everybody he's
being indicted by the Biden doj for
trying to wipe a server I kid you not it
is beautiful irony and I'm just I gotta
be honest I'm very very glad they did it
because you know it's only going to be a
matter of days maybe maybe hours until
Hillary Clinton gets indicted for
actually having her server deleted and
phone smashed with hammers now I suppose
the the reason they're indicting Trump
for this is so they can make the
argument that hey you you claimed for
years that that wiping a server was a
criminal act and here's Trump trying to
do it now you have to be against Trump
but it actually does the inverse now I'm
gonna be like you said no reasonable
prosecutor would bring charges against
Hillary so clearly you are not
reasonable prosecutors right now we got
this big story about Hunter Biden they
tried sneaking in an unprecedented
blanket immunity deal for Hunter on all
charges and the judge caught it yeah see
this is what they're doing the Biden doj
corrupt as they come
and we're watching it happen in real
time so we'll talk about that plus
ladies and gentlemen Anheuser-Busch is
laying off hundreds of people this is
crazy that's how bad it's been with Bud
Light sales so winning the culture War
before we get started with all that news
my friends I also got some more news if
you go to castbrew.com support the show
by buying our coffee you can join the
cast Brew Coffee Club where you'll get
three different bags every month there's
the ground and the whole bean version
I hate to say it but uh we sold out in a
day I think it's a day Mr bocus pumpkin
spice experience sold out stand your
grounds a medium roast whole and ground
have completely sold out uh so wow thank
you guys so much for for buying our
coffee and supporting the show we will
work as quickly as possible to get that
restocked but um could take a couple
weeks in the meantime you can buy any of
the other other uh Blends we've got
we've got unwoke decaf sleepy Joe and of
course I gotta tell you if you haven't
tried Appalachian nights you're missing
out I think it's the best coffee I've
ever had but uh man we didn't I don't I
don't even think we got a sample of the
pumpkin spice yeah we've had the the
initial production line where we got it
and we like formulated and taste it and
everything but we put this up like a day
ago and y'all so y'all bought every
single one of them we're gonna have to
get that restocked but thank you so much
for supporting us by uh buying our
coffee at Casper we sponsor ourselves
because we have to build that parallel
economy don't forget to also go to
timcast.com click that uh join us button
we're gonna have a members only
uncensored show coming up at about 10
p.m and as member is you can call in
submit you can submit questions to call
in and talk to our guests the reason why
I think it's gonna be so great as we
talk about the parallel economy is that
joining us today smash the like button
is the harman Brothers uh these are the
guys behind sound of Freedom's
distribution and Angel Studios do you
guys want to introduce yourselves sure
Neil Harmon I'm a co-founder and CEO of
Angel Studios
you can carry the mic around with you oh
great great yeah Neil Harmon co-founder
and CEO of Angel Studios
and I'm Jeff Harmon also co-founder
and there's another there's another
Harmon brother back there yeah we just
don't have enough space so we got
another Harmony there are three more
there's three more there's too many
holler too many Harmon Brothers uh but
you guys uh you guys are the the
founders of uh Angel Studios yes it's
amazing parallel economy we've got to
build our own spaces build our own
culture you guys just had a smashing
success with sound of Freedom we're big
fans so right on do you want to mention
anything about the studio so people can
understand we'll get started so angel
means ownership uh Angel Investors were
the first to invest in Broadway right
they are the ones who made those shows
those shows possible and um and it's the
same thing here we've got over a hundred
thousand people who've invested in the
shows that we've done dry bar comedy The
Chosen Tuttle twins sound of Freedom the
people are bringing these shows to
market right on well it's going to be
fun we certainly will talk about that
there's this funny article from Vox
where they said sound and free a sound
of freedom is as dark and dangerous as
child trafficking itself which is the
most psychotic and insane thing but I
love it because sound of Freedom was
originally owned by Disney right it was
made by Fox I think yes and then you
guys secure the distribution rights is
that how it went down yeah so Fox uh
originally made it then Disney acquired
Fox and then uh the producer Eduardo
varastagi who was here yeah he managed
to get it out of out of uh Disney and
then uh and then we got the rights who
knew that fox was so into Q on it I know
that's crazy can you believe it
wow they were they they did it before it
was a thing
it invented it
we also have Hannah Claire broomallow
hanging out hi I'm I'm a writer for Tim
cast
Ro so happy to be here with you guys and
Ian's here also yes I am I'm very
excited to be here with you guys great
to finally meet I've been a long time
coming so let's roll this ball down the
hill indeed we show I'm searched.com
it's gonna be a fun one guys pleasure to
meet you where's here's the big news
today we're all waiting eagerly to hear
about the potential indictments it was
presumed that Trump would be indicted on
something related to January 6 but
instead this is the most ironic and
hilarious thing the Daily Mail reports
Trump accused of trying to delete the
Mar-A-Lago server and wipe surveillance
footage in bombshell new indictment
ex-president hit with more charges and
head of clubs maintenance is also
implicated in classified documents case
the long story short of it Trump
apparently told some guy he wanted uh as
they say the former president allegedly
told aids to wipe security footage from
his Florida Club server as a way to foil
investigators probing the removal of
classified documents from the White
House see that's an opinion statement
they're making an accusation just
because Trump wanted a server with
security footage wiped doesn't mean he
intended to commit a crime by doing so
he could have just been like oh we're
gonna do a routine like wipe of the
servers but I digress Carlos D Oliveira
mar-a Lagos head of Maintenance has been
named as the third defendant alongside
the former president and his valet Walt
NADA both developments present
additional legal Jeopardy for the former
president who spent uh part of Thursday
blah blah just imagine this Imagine This
we've it's been years since they
outright said they will not indict
Hillary Clinton for actually deleting
public record
for having phones smashed with hammers
so you're sitting there as Trump and
you're like we're totally allowed to do
this Comey himself said it okay well you
know wipe the server I guess oh nope now
they got you now you're now you're gonna
be criminally charged and arrested
sounds like they're having it I it
actually feels like they're having fun
that they are like you know let's just
get them let's get Trump on what what
Hillary didn't get on it'll be just just
desserts for Donald Trump I don't know
if that's true it's hard for me not to
look at it and think you know now that
they're arresting his head of
Maintenance in his valet they're trying
to make him feel guilty for putting
Regular People In Harm's Way like they
are trying everything to get him to take
a plea deal to sort of bow down to this
it seems kind of sick
man I just was singing to Hillary When
Donald Trump was on stage with her and
he was like you'd be if I was President
you'd be in jail they just you never
forget they never forget one of the best
debate moments in modern history I think
that's the reason why they're putting
trying to put him in jail right now
because they're like you do not do that
to the Democratic party in public you do
not say those things directly to Hillary
Clinton Public unless you want to face
the Wrath is like what this feels like I
mean it just Republicans sit around
doing nothing and Democrats are lobbying
Molotov cocktails figuratively and
literally in New York they quite
literally did and now they're trying to
arrest Republican electors they're
charging them with felonies they're
indicting Trump again they're going
after his maintenance guy I just it just
kind of feels like the Republican party
is sitting there going
oh no or they're they're in on it
they're they're what can they do
Republicans exactly so in uh say a
Republican state like West Virginia
where you have Republican DA's they can
start criminally charging Democrats
they can say hey hold on there a minute
you just fight
fight fire I mean is it fighting fire
with fire I mean is there when it comes
to say like Hillary Clinton Barack Obama
Joe Biden do any of the crimes they've
committed extend to the jurisdiction of
these conservative or republican or even
in some cases like Republican
libertarian uh counties or districts the
answer is of course yes absolutely Joe
Biden for instance there was already
talk from Republicans about potentially
bringing charges against Joe Biden
because if he's operating out of certain
territories or certain areas I mean a
lot of these people have property in
Florida right Rhonda santis and the
Florida DA's could be going after people
but not a single not a single ba not a
single Republican anywhere has come up
with any reason or has found any crime
committed look but they are they're like
um isn't Congress about to impeach Biden
so they're kind of throwing back they're
not they're not nope no they say that
like uh Kevin McCarthy said this may
reach the level of an impeachment
inquiry okay okay so so I just heard
that like two days ago and and they say
say these things so that you hear
they're going to impeach Biden when what
he actually said is we might
ask the question should Biden be
impeached we may think about it we might
like like they're not even asking should
Biden be impeacher saying you know if
this keeps happening we might have to
ask each other if this reaches a level
of impeachment I mean I think you asked
a good question what do we do or what do
people do in general how do you fight
back against the machine I don't well
understood is to do just Judicial System
right that's you would think so but then
I see Sam Beckman freed released today
from his charge and he's walking on his
10 billion dollars and he said he's
going free Hillary Clinton didn't get
charged for emails James Comey said she
did nothing wrong Hunter Biden had a pat
on the wrist of course that may be no
longer the case with some of the charges
maybe being put back on the table
um but it feels like using the legal
system to disrupt the people that are in
at the top of the legal system isn't the
best method so how do we how how do I
mean I like to make culture building
culture so yeah yeah well we went
through this because we were sued by
Disney and we learned pretty quickly
that fighting the lawsuit with Disney in
Los Angeles
is not a place you want to be
so we were handed all kinds of crazy
crazy like our trial
um for example
we had a someone who was going to come
testify from Google that we had gone to
work with Google to try to get licensing
to be able to skip stuff in in TV shows
and movies and the judge said last
minute this person can't test them one
enough right morning enough and those
those decisions are decided 30 days in
advance yep and then and then after that
the judge lets Disney testify Google's
motives they with their expert so crazy
crazy stuff and uh and so we just
decided we've got to get out of court as
fast as we possibly can and fight in the
marketplace that's one place where we
feel like we still can fight and we
settled in uh 2020
and um and our company you know when we
were sued we did like 8 million and um
and here we are we have a formerly
Disney film that uh is winning in the
market it's like 130 million people that
don't know about your lawsuit did you
really quickly explain like what was a
lawsuit or what what's public about it
so the way that we started Angel Studios
is 10 years ago four brothers and a
cousin we had young kids
like nine and under and we wanted to
watch really great compelling stories
but have them match values like my
nine-year-old I didn't want him to go
and speak to his sisters in certain ways
when they were young and so we created
this technology that would allow you to
skip you know Skip certain language or
skip nudity or whatever
and um and we thought if we launched
this technology we're going to collect a
group of people who care about
storytelling and care about family and
then we'll be able to then we'll be able
to distribute
news stories to these people better than
Hollywood can so that was that was the
original Vision so we built the the
filtering technology the skipping
technology
uh 2016 it started to succeed and then
we got sued and then uh 2020 we settled
and then we pivoted to during that
lawsuit we pivoted to creating our own
stories you you said you settled for 8
million is that we said it was like 7.8
uh uh uh so it was a 62 and a half
million dollar
um judgment and they basically said
we'll forgive that if you'll pay for
some of our legal fees and uh and we
settled in 2020. so our thought process
was
after fighting for four and a half years
and Disney had probably spent they'd
spent tens of millions of dollars trying
to destroy an angel
and we had spent millions of dollars
trying to fight back it was just we got
to get out of their game
we can't fight inside of the system well
and they cannot send you that's one of
the challenges and the whole entire
Hollywood System knows that this
downtown LA court they call it the bank
like they call it like it's called the
bank because you can just take anybody
there and get money out if you're a
Hollywood studio and so the the
and and we we actually got hit really
hard by Disney and so there there was
this this moment where you're just
realizing
you can't fight them on their ground we
just gotta opt out of this system
and build an entire parallel
uh Studio system to the current
Hollywood system or else we can't we
can't rise up through their system and
so how did you so people don't know you
guys the harman Brothers do commercial
work too you guys have done a lot of
like The Squatty Potty stuff you did the
the rainbow poop coming out of the
Unicorn yeah commercial iconic so did
you take your like private money and
then you were able to rebuild after the
settlement or like how did you come back
from it basically because I think a lot
of people might think you get grounded
to dust just yeah oh well I mean we
understood yeah and we don't know of a
company who's a startup that has
survived from a Disney lawsuit so we we
feel very grateful but
um one thing that happened is we had two
major successes while we were in
bankruptcy through going through the
lawsuit dry bar comedy which gets over a
billion views a year it's stand-up
comedy that's funny for everyone
um and then the chosen which is like a
top five TV series
um and
we just started growing like crazy
during this lawsuit and uh and then
Disney and and then we had a trustee
during the bankruptcy who was in charge
of her company we had to file bankruptcy
yes but yeah to protect us from Disney
there's a chapter 11 bankruptcy has this
format where you can actually use it as
a shield against a predator so we used
bankruptcy to protect us from Disney yes
and and then
um
uh as soon as they as soon as the
trustees saw how fast we were growing
with this parallel system that we were
building
he said to the judge these guys are
going to be able to pay off the entire
62 million dollars and Disney said wait
wait a second we actually don't want to
be paid back we just you know just put
them into chapter seven yeah just put
them into chapter seven and the judge is
like oh you guys aren't acting your own
financial interest I can't trust you
anymore
um why didn't they want to be paid back
because they wanted they wanted us dead
they wanted us chapter seven is
liquidation they wanted all our assets
sold off they wanted the judge to say
you don't have 62 million today so sell
everything off and then and then we get
what's what's left but the but the
trustee said no these guys are growing
so fast they're going to be able to pay
off this whole 62 million dollars I just
need a plan plus interest wow and
Disney's like no that's not what we want
and uh wow this is like no thank you
please please no they're like no we
don't want to be paid off and the judge
is like why the whole point of chapter
11 bankruptcy or chapter 7 is you're
supposed to want to get paid back not
just destroy your company right and so
he said I'm not going to let you do that
and then he threw it out or what no no
no then Disney said no okay we'll settle
if you guys won't ever use your
technology to filter our stuff again
we'll we'll forgive the 62 million you
guys pay you know part of our legal fees
part of the legal fees and uh and we'll
call it good we just went we like I said
like Jeffrey said that we have a hundred
thousand people who have invested who
who helped make the content decisions we
went to our investors and we said guys
we told you we'd fight this all the way
we have this chance that we can just go
after original storytelling instead of
skipping over Hollywood stuff we make
our own stuff we tell our own stories
and we control those stories what do you
guys want to do do you want to fight
this all the way or do you want to tell
our own stories and 84 of our people
said let's just go tell the stories and
then we offered to buy out the rest of
them did you get inspired during the pro
the court process to start your own
storytelling so actually we thought
about doing our own storytelling at the
beginning that's the only reason
Jeffrey's involved yeah I told Neil when
he came to me Neil and Jordan came to me
and they were like let's build this
system that skips and mutes content in
movies and I was like uh that happened a
while back and everybody there's like 14
companies that did this and every single
one got sued out of existence but how
what's the what's the ground's pursuing
um it's copyright copyright arguments
but it seems weird because if I had a
movie on at home and I skipped it that's
not copyright but if you have a
technology that does it because the
technology uses there's a there's a a
law called The Family movie Act of 2005
that allows you to skip and mute content
that's transmitted
over the Internet we read that and said
that means as long as the customers
bought the content and as long as they
make the choices then as long as they're
making the choices then we can provide
technology to skip and mute content
Disney came in and said no the dmca
you're you're you're decrypting oh what
I don't you know well that Neil can
explain it better I think the best way
to explain it was this the ninth circuit
basically said we see vid Angel's
argument
that was your company yeah our company
at the time was called vid angel that
sounds like a good thing we see it this
is a novel interpretation a lot we also
see Disney's argument and it just so
happens if we go with vid Angels there's
a big hole in copyright law
yeah so we can't do that we're gonna go
with Disney and and we're like wait a
second The Family movie Act was like an
exemption under the copyright law why
you know that's what it is a whole it's
designed it's designed to be an
exemption but but we weren't going to
win in in in in that Court we weren't
going to win in that system what if you
open source technology and just release
it to the wind
we actually uh we actually did set up a
foundation in the middle of the lawsuit
and announced that and Disney came
screaming to the courts and saying that
they that they needed to seize the
company from us uh before we uh let any
assets out of the company so because
that was ultimately what's that they
stop you from doing it well we were just
asking the court if they would let us do
it and the Disney stopped
wait so you're saying the technology
which seems completely honest in today's
day and age not pretty simple pretty
simple yeah is is not available I mean
there's got to be open source versions
of this so we settled and we sold that
angel yeah off and it still works you
can you can it just doesn't work for
Disney's it just does not work for
Disney or Warner Brothers yep
but it's doing well you can't run a
plug-in on your own browser watching
movies is that what it is
yeah so you you you can
um but you can't but you can't do it
with a modern streaming device so you
can't do it through your iPad you can't
do it through your Roku all iPhone all
those things that's what that's a VHS
you can do it on a browser you could do
it like through a Chrome browser with an
extension but you can't get it on an
iPhone or something because it would
have to
oh my modern device you wouldn't be able
to do it with I guess technically if you
use Chrome on your phone to watch which
would not be as good as this is the
streaming app Chrome on your phone
doesn't support extensions
right so so so what you're saying is the
thing that you made actually would go
between an app yeah it would basically
it would basically go like if you have
your Netflix account you tie your
Netflix account to vid Angel and it
would go and it would be you you'd make
your choices you'd say oh I want to skip
nudity and then it would go up and it
would in the cloud it would contact your
Netflix account
get your Netflix stream
it and send it down to your you know
your iPhone or free to your Roku or
whatever and that you know that's the
only way it could be done on a modern
streaming device and you know for it was
like 14 of the market is on a desktop
and you know uh uh 86 of the market at
the time was all on streaming devices so
that's how we delivered the technology
right right well I I get it I get it
yeah when you guys settled and then you
bounced did you bounce out of California
after that are you still sticking around
Cali we're in Utah okay so were you were
never based in California that's just
where the lawsuit happened yeah so what
happened you after you settled like what
was the what was the impetus for the the
next generation of Harman
of Angel Studios yeah yeah so we after
we settled we we bought angel.com and
then we re rebranded as Angel Studios
um you know Angel Bean investor and uh
dry bar we had the chosen yeah then we
just started expanding yeah Tuttle twins
which you can see I'm sporting right
here
um the wing feather Saga which is
fantasy Tuttle twins is like a freedom
education thing for kids Ron Paul right
yeah yeah
it fit in that World
um and then you've got
um
sound of Freedom now which is fun
because we went through all this battle
and and fox was acquired by Disney
during our lawsuit and this parallel
story was happening and then we ended up
with the rights to sound of Freedom here
in 2023 Fox paid for sound of freedom to
get made is that how it worked and then
Disney bottom so Disney owned it yep yep
and they were suing you when you bought
it from them or did you wait till after
the lawsuit no it was after the lawsuit
and you purchased it back yeah yeah well
they actually the team purchased it back
and then we licensed from we became the
distributor after that the team who's
the team is
straight up did he raise money to I
don't know if that's yeah yeah yeah and
he uh and he worked with Disney for like
a year and a half trying to get get it
out to negotiate to get it out of there
I love this Fox News you know very very
uh
Fox right yeah we mentioned this earlier
that we have this article from vox.com
take a look this from a couple uh like
two weeks ago sound of Freedom wants to
raise awareness about child trafficking
here's what it what it's really doing oh
what it's really doing I love this let
me just uh do a quick search you know
Fox used to take a look it says Qs that
extremism is at least as dark and
dangerous as the very thing sound of
Freedom wants to combat the crazy thing
about about it is like
that fox made it well Fox made it now
compared to law order SVU it's it's
there's no evil government actors
snatching kids under their arms and like
running out of a pizza restaurant or
anything like that it's just it's a law
enforcement story yeah Disney wanted at
one point right yeah but they wanted it
it wasn't extreme they bought it but
when they don't have it anymore it is
Extreme I mean I think what you're doing
with moving to sort of uh creating
culture through the marketplace is
really interesting in some ways it
reminds me of what Matt Gates did saying
uh you know uh Jack Smith the the
prosecutor that's investigating uh Trump
he just was like well you can't have any
more money this isn't worth it this is
this is craziness and I think in some
way really that's ultimately I mean we
talk about a lot with like Public Square
uh the dollar is one way to leverage
power against this institution so
internally Republicans who are in
Congress could theoretically cut off
some of these investigations if they cut
off doj funding and if you guys are able
to say like we know people who are
willing to spend money for entertainment
that they feel represents them and we
make the entertainment then we're able
to circulate this money through people
who have the values and I find that
really interesting but we also learned
like I um we I went to cinemacon this
year cinemacon is where all the studios
come to
talk to the theaters so the exhibitors
are the theaters and those are
mainstream Americans these are 3 000
plus owners of theaters all across this
country and they're just normal everyday
middle class Heartland Americans and so
the studios come in and at cinemacon
they like it's the most bizarre
experience where you've got these middle
American Theater owners and then you got
these Studios there coming out of their
bubble and then they're just trying to
sell their content to the theater owners
and so they're they're kind of like
there's
almost uh there's an almost adversarial
adversarial release relationship but at
the same time they're sitting there
whining and dining the theater is trying
to just say okay we have to work with
you I was walking around with this shirt
on this Angel shirt and they're and I
couldn't make it down the hallway
without
five six different theater owners just
stopping and being like hey they pull
out a cross and they're like I'm on your
side
why are you Whispering keep going and
I'm like thank you but but it's it's um
but the amount of support from the
theaters made us realize there's just
this realization as long as we can make
it economically viable
for alternative content to go to the
theaters they will pick
that content
they they'll support it yeah and that's
how the money's made listen to this July
3rd we had
2634 theaters for sound of Freedom July
7th
2852. July 14th
3265. July 21st
2285 July 28th which is coming tomorrow
what day are we this Friday
3411. this is like the first movie I've
ever heard of that has expanded the
number of theaters for four Fridays you
might have misread the number I misread
you I thought the third number you read
was a two thousand but it was two it was
3285 it went from 3000 to 65 to 85 to 3
to uh 3411. I've noticed it like
consciously the way it's expanding too
yes it's a caught fire like yeah
psychological thought listen to this
stat this is just on uh Reddit thread
sound of Freedom has a shot at 27 State
straight days over 3 million dollars
even end game didn't do that and I'll
believe only a single digit number of
movies have done that somewhere someone
correct me if I'm wrong and everybody's
like a Titanic didn't do it they made it
only to 19 days I'd be interested to
know what the record is that's just a
Reddit thread are tickets more expensive
because inflation obviously has got to
be playing a role sure sure yeah how
much are they now so the average ticket
price is like 11.80 or something like
that yeah and if you go back to like
Passion of the Christ it was somewhere
seven or eight bucks change yeah the
sound of Freedom was number two for the
uh July 14th the 20th yes yes
and we I think we've had four or five
days that we've been number one and um
but um one other thing that's different
is that they've they've re uh factored
all the theaters to do these lounge
chairs I love it that's what we had and
so it's actually going it's changed even
though the ticket price has gone up your
actual number of seats are smaller and
so it's kind of changed the economic
environment yeah Southern frames got
several days uh July 4th it was number
one uh July 10th and 11th was number one
and July 20th it was number one yes yeah
it's amazing and growing yes you
mentioned um crowdfunding because Angel
Studios is a crowdfunding model you see
a hundred thousand Angel Investors that
come in and they vote on what do you
ever find that that causes problems like
chaos within the the structure of the
organism
so far what we've seen is this
incredible
um aptitude for choosing a hit
like the our very first theatrical
release was called his only son just
this little 250 000 film nobody would
have guessed to take this film to
theaters like you would not this is not
the kind of film you'd take to theaters
it doesn't have a big enough budget
doesn't have any named people first time
director like this film shouldn't have
gone to theaters from Lebanon the main
actress is from Iran and the main and
the boy who plays Isaac Abraham Isaac
he's from Israel like they're just no
namers that are but it did well but we
got the guild score and we're like whoa
whoa and then we put it out there for
crowdfunding and it raised uh 1.25
million in 100 hours and we were
expecting to raise four hundred thousand
dollars in 30 days and we're just like
okay we gotta lean into this because
what the guild is saying and then it hit
number three in the box office against
some huge huge temples but I would
assume this is one of the things that
maybe Hollywood is forgetting is
important like you guys are talking to
actual people who are interested in
movie who would put their money behind
movies and saying what do you want to
see whereas Hollywood has
their own Enclave of people and they're
asking each other it's such an echo
chamber how could you get accurate
feedback on what a good movie would be
yeah yes you said the guild is the guild
the small percentage of the total fund
crowdfunders
anybody who has invested in a previous
project can be a member of The Guild and
that those guys are are the ones who
decide the future of angels production
there's about a hundred thousand people
in the angel Guild and the idea here is
is that they replace the Hollywood
Gatekeepers Hollywood's awesome to all
the creators the Craftsmen in Hollywood
they're great The Gatekeepers are the
problem and they they they're the ones
who decide like this it has to have this
much uh diversity
figure or this much LBT lgbtq it has to
have this much nudity this many sex
scenes whatever they're the ones just
like deciding these things for the the
content creators and so the filmmakers
are
um they kind of move either direction
but The Gatekeepers are holding holding
the grounds and so the angel Guild is a
replacement of the Hollywood Gatekeepers
and that so we get 60 filmmakers a week
submitting to Angel Studios and then
these The Guild goes through and votes
on that content and about 95 percent of
it fails and five percent gets through
to the next step yep to the next step
when someone submits they submit oh yeah
the torch yeah so they'll submit like a
five minute short film or or in the case
of sound of Freedom they submitted the
entire film
anecdotally before I show you guys tell
me the torch you call is like this
prototype five minute piece or whatever
full fulfill so technically sound of
Freedom was a torch it's from the Statue
of Liberty's torch I didn't know that
the Statue of Liberty was crowdfunded
yes by French people
yes
Frederick bartaldi couldn't get any
governments to fund the Statue of
Liberty and he wanted had this dream of
creating the biggest piece of art and we
all know artists will try to get their
budget from wherever they can yes that's
right they'll go anywhere to get their
budget but he wanted to create the
biggest piece of art around the biggest
idea in the world then he first tried
the Suez Canal before he visited the
America and and he got shot down he
visits America and he decides this is
the biggest idea America is so he goes
back he gets the president of the United
States to say I think that's a great
idea takes back a letter because the
president didn't offer him any money I
mean even the Washington Monument was
crowdfunded I don't know if you knew
that but the um because the government
wouldn't pay for stuff like that back
then and they have times have changed
they had principles
um so so they they he goes back to to
France and he raises just enough money
to build the torch and a hand and he
sets it up in the Parks and he takes
people up in the top of the torch and he
takes pit blast black and white pictures
of them there's a whole bunch of them
online you can see these black and white
pictures of this torch and he raised 14
million dollars in today's money over a
decade he'd give out little pins yeah
little things it was the first
Kickstarter campaign yes first
crowdfunding campaign yep and he and he
spends a decade and he builds it so we
just modeled the entire brand of our
company is we have torches which are the
the filmmakers even like every year we
do what are called the torch Awards
where we actually give away a a copper
replica of the torch of the Statue of
Liberty to filmmakers so there's um yeah
we the idea is around the original
crowdfunding campaign I think a lot of
the problems in today's society could be
solved with crowdfunding a lot of like
roads you're really worried about the
roads don't wait for the government you
know set up but we just need maybe some
Organization for it like an app or
something where you can like locally
send some you know some tips yeah yeah
and what what happens as soon as you
engage the crowd like when we raise the
smartest money we can raise for
advertising is from the crowd because
everybody comes in they can do they
maybe throw 50 bucks at it or 20 bucks
or whatever and then they go out and
they bring it drag all their neighbors
into the theaters so if you get seven
thousand ten thousand people
crowdfunding a project
you've got 10 000 an army of 10 000
people out dragging everybody they know
into those theaters to try to make that
movie profitable of the hundred thousand
Angel Investors that you currently have
uh do they all invest in every movie no
no they don't all invest every single
movie we bring on a giant chunk of new
people over half how do people sign up
to invest
invest.angel.com is where
um the the different projects go up for
to raise money there's a link there at
angel.com yeah is it the same way for
writers and stuff that want to submit
like as if you need more another
thousand submissions so so we're not
currently set up to
um to take scripts uh we only can take
torches like only like projects that
show a vision for what you're trying to
create
um but um there's also a link on there
for the angel accelerator fund and they
they have they actually
um
they partner with some filmmakers to
help create torches what's it called the
angel accelerate accelerator fund and
they'll they'll help people they don't
have money but have a great idea or like
a great really great they're gonna have
to bring their own money like they match
torch like if a torch costs 100 Grand
they might put up 50 and then the torch
would be then the the filmmaker would
have to bring 50.
let's talk about uh winning the culture
War so I think one of the reasons sound
of freedom is so important is uh making
133 million dollars several days at
number one proving that outside as you
mentioned The Gatekeepers there is a
path towards success yes younger people
need to be able to look at the stuff
that we're creating and say there is
another way to succeed you don't have to
go through the corrupt machine
we have this news story that I think
plays into this Bud Light Brewery is
laying off hundreds of U.S workers well
I'm kind of sad for these people but at
the same time if you've been working at
Bud Light where over the past four
months this controversy has been going
on you had to know this was coming not
only that but several bottling plants
had already laid off hundreds of people
so y'all should look if you work for Bud
Light I would only say I am personally I
would be surprised if you were not
trying to find another job because they
are firing people but this is a sign
that the Old Guard and The Gatekeepers
are failing they are losing out get well
go broke and we're starting to see the
inverse with sound of freedom for
instance there is an inverse to get woke
go broke starting to emerge and that is
don't be woke make money or however
you'd phrase it I don't know someone
come up with something catchier stay
based get laced
get paid yeah uh yeah something like
we'll let the chat take care stay back
guys think of something that's the
inverse of this because
this is this is what we're seeing now we
were just talking about you know Donald
Trump is getting indicted and I was
saying this earlier how do you people
like what do we do how do we win we're
watching this corruption I'm like
they're going the wrong route going this
procedural procedural route to try and
win a culture war is a losing battle and
and we should all know this because it's
what Republicans were doing in 2016.
Democrats were going to the media
they're going to TV they were lying
cheating and stealing they were pushing
false narratives russiagate Etc to shape
the minds of the of individuals in this
country they controlled institutions
they were censoring information on media
they knew culture comes first then
politics
now what do you have you have the Biden
doj protecting uh Hunter Biden with this
with this insane plea agreement they
tried giving him indicting Donald Trump
again and we got uh SBF getting his
charges dropped not all of them but how
convenient you give Democrats money you
don't go to jail I guess
but I don't think that's going to play
very well because if the influence that
is generated in culture is coming from
the likes of Angel Studios if the
products they're buying are no longer
Bud Light if they're not watching Fox
News even or CNN anymore they're coming
to other places yeah it's not like they
just stopped right exactly going
somewhere else exactly and that means
eventually Democrats aren't going to be
able to pull this stuff off they're
going to slowly start losing political
power because they're trying to win by
writing laws or or utilizing government
which I've been saying a long time
doesn't work Republicans keep trying to
do that doesn't work great example
you've got on the books laws preventing
adults from engaging in lascivious acts
with children these laws have been on
the books forever West Virginia for
instance has it plain as day yet the
police allow children to be part of lewd
and lascivious shows at adult venues
child drag performances all ages drag
shows that are explicit because the law
has to be enforced the police won't
enforce it though because of the culture
because we're at a point or we were
where you have these uh you had this
show where it said it's not going to
lick itself and there's kids there and
the cops go I'm not getting involved in
this even though it is illegal
discernably codified the cops won't do
anything about it because the culture is
fractured and there's no clear winner
the police are only going to do what
they think the majority would support
it's not a freedom is winning if Angel
Studios is winning if shows like ours if
cast brew coffee is winning if Bud Light
is failing eventually people are going
to say I'm here to be on The Winning
Side law enforcement's going to come out
and be like we're going to go arrest the
person breaking the law it's illegal for
women unmarried women to skydive in
Florida on Sunday
is a cop going to arrest a woman who
skydives on Sunday of course not why
it's illegal because because the law
actually doesn't matter what matters
what police are willing to enforce
so if we win the culture War
then the police are going to enforce
what the people want enforced
yeah I think it's true I mean
the part of government is the consent of
the people right so if you disagree with
law not only can you fight it but also
your town can start to say like this
doesn't make sense I mean there are all
kinds of old laws on the books the the
skydiving in Florida one might be an
example of of things that we would not
allow or accept I believe there's a town
in Connecticut where your husband's
allowed to uh
beat his wife on the town hall steps
during the day and that never got
repealed it's just there now if this
happened we would all be appalled like
we know some things are wrong and I
can't say why that one was on the books
ever but uh so much of what we do is
just
choosing to say like I'm not going to
give in to this anymore and again I
think it's important to go back to the
fact that for a long time you know you'd
get these things companies doing
something you didn't agree with but
there were no Alternatives right like I
remember uh I can't even remember like
if you wanted to boycott uh a shoe
company well that shoe company is also
owned by this company that's also doing
this and like we saw this a little bit
with uh Bud Light that you know some
people were like well I'll buy this one
it actually is all under the
Anheuser-Busch
umbrella so maybe we give credit to the
internet here for being active and
alerting to people to sort of the
network of companies but uh it is really
interesting to see people actively
seeking out change and reviewing like
what they're being told to do and saying
I don't want to anymore I think it
happens it doesn't happen at once too
it'll happen like probably like a seven
year lag you make a movie that changes
like a nine-year-old's mind and then
when they're 16 that's when the power
begins to shift yes absolutely you guys
see that with your own kids well yeah
totally and that's the reason that we
started this is because we could see
um
that this was a long game right like the
way that we were going to actually
change
the world for our children for their
children was by not not by going and
coming here to DC and lobbying and and
fighting over red and blue politics but
it was just
in our home yeah with our kids telling
really great stories that help them
understand true principles when The Dark
Knight Rises came out I had I was at
CPAC that year or something around there
and I remember sitting on this panel
discussion and them saying you know if
you're conservative and you want your
children who are interested in politics
to make a difference you actually
shouldn't send them to DC you should
send them to Hollywood and I wish I
could give credit to whoever said that
I'd forgotten the panelist's name at
this point but it's interesting because
they're basically making the point 10
years ago and you guys said Angel was
founded in 2013 that you guys ultimately
proved which is like if you want to
redirect culture you need people who
have those values in a position to make
that content I mean it's we know a lot
of people who are creative and who have
ideas but I don't remember who was on
the show talking about the the
infrastructure Behind movie production
like all all the things you need to rent
and the film equipment like there has to
be stepping stones to build this and
ultimately you guys have proven
redirecting the energy and Steve Jobs
says that the most powerful person in
the world is a Storyteller um that he's
famous for that statement and you can
see this with sound of Freedom Alejandro
Monteverde goes and Mexican guy
grew up it was affected by cartels
his dad was and his brother were
murdered murdered by a cartel and he
builds this movie in this story
to help unite and to fight this issue
and Neil was just telling me last night
that some Bill and what state was it I
think it was Wisconsin Wisconsin or
something like a local legislator put up
a bill that's called the sound of
Freedom Bill and they're changing laws
because of this film
and there was a wow there was a
um uh law enforcement officer down in
Texas who after watching the film
started classes in their community and
they're teaching teenage girls what
signs to look for how pedophiles attack
through through social media those
classes are happening all over the last
churches right-wing extremism
protect your family yeah
um for Predators crazy stuff they showed
it at Congress I think sound of Freedom
yesterday uh Tuesday night Tuesday
nights Donald Trump's made a comment
that he wants to give traffickers the
death penalty uh women as well as men I
wonder I mean yeah yeah I'm not I was
like geez why does he keep jumping to
the death
look traffickers people that rape kids
and sell them probably deserve death
but the death penalty I think the
statistics are they get it wrong like
four percent of the time like too much
four out of 100 people are innocent and
so it's not a practical solution in my
opinion that's my opinion I I don't I
don't like I I believe they deserve it
but if you can't practically make that
happen without like if you were if you
were trying to protect a kid who is
about to be attacked by someone use
whatever Force you can to save the life
of that child from the person committing
the crime right yep if we've captured
someone and Kamala Harris walks up to me
and says see that guy over there he
deserves death I'm going to be like I
don't trust you lady I mean that guy may
be evil for sure but yeah man I'm not
gonna sign off on Kamala Harris's
request I know she's the worst example I
can think of you know when it comes to
who would be advocating right but once
the power's there it's gonna be the
worst person right yeah granted I am
grateful that Trump is entering the
discussion it shows how powerful this
movie has been that Donald Trump is
entering that discussion and
participating and he had his own
screening right yeah but I mean I we've
got you wouldn't believe like it's not
just Republicans that are asking for
screeners of this movie
like everybody's asking for a
screenshots
there are leftist Publications that are
saying Q Anon and stuff the guardian did
it but the critic the corporate press
critic reviews are still what like 75 or
yeah I think it's down to 70 now it
slowly gets chipped away up but
um but the but there are people on both
sides of the aisle that are very
powerful all and state leaders all over
the world like asking
should see this I I for example tomorrow
we're flying to El Salvador yeah and we
are meeting with bukles
premiere of the film but oh that's
fantastic he's public I can say that one
but there there are who else
you would be amazed and I'm hoping that
some of them when they watch it because
they're they're watching it so we're
talking not that they're going to be on
this uh live stream but if they are or
somebody who is uh we are hoping that
one of them will come out speak up speak
up like just just stop this
Ridiculousness everybody who's seen this
movie knows it has nothing to do with
politics and has nothing to do with
conspiracy theories to be the most
bipartisan issue passing child
trafficking and it's just a true story
but that's what I keep saying law order
svu's on the on the air for 20 some odd
years I think it's still on the air
right it's it's a very very popular show
about law enforcement trying to protect
victims of sexual abuse you guys
acquired a movie and distributed and
they're so desperate to attack it it's
insane yeah but I I think I think you're
hitting a point here and Russell Brand
when he covered sound of Freedom he
covers this point I think there's like I
I I'm just racking my mind why on Earth
is everybody attack like is the left
attacking this so hard specifically the
left and I I came up with four theories
uh the first one is Russell Brands which
I didn't come up with he came up with he
just said this is a model coming out of
left field it's completely bypassing all
the Hollywood Gatekeepers they hate it
and they hate it so much that they hate
this model and the fact they can't
control it because they have their
oligopoly yeah that they would rather
attack the model with these conspiracy
theories and just forget about the fact
that the message number two there's
groups of people who are so partisan
that when the dog whistles come out they
just say uh my team's on this side so
therefore I can't watch it yeah there's
cognitive dissonance where they're not
weighing this is millions of kids being
trafficked versus my partisan politics
so so I'll address that right many
people complain about Chris Evans
politics because he goes on Twitter and
he says woke stuff he's in the movie
Knives Out
I can separate art from the artist I
thought knives that was great I think
great Ryan Johnson also has questionable
statements but I thought uh uh uh Knives
Out was good I I I actually liked how he
Incorporated the politics into it they
can't see these tribalists you're
referred to can't seem to do that they
can't do it they can't separate it and
then the third one is where you get a
little more controversial but it's like
uh you've got 150 billion dollar
industry these have there's cartels that
are child trafficking cartels and
they've got their talking points and
that journalists are inadvertently
grabbing these talking points probably
because of one or two but they're
grabbing cartel talking points to try to
downplay how significant of a problem
this is and number three is they're just
all number sorry number four is they're
just all in it like they're all in it
together and there's just and so it
probably as Russell Brands got it first
and it Cascades down to the bottom one
um did the evil just everybody all these
people are evil but there's but it's
it's most likely economics driving it
partisan incism driving it and then the
other two are probably smaller ones yeah
I mean I think the partisan one is so
true if especially if you're getting
people who are like you know like you're
saying with the theater owners who hold
up their crosses to you in secret like
these people being like I am against
child trafficking but I don't want to
say it too loud that's a little weird
but I guess if that's your team's part
line I don't know I identify Russell's
uh idea that it's a economic Warfare
essentially or like they don't like the
model of coming in from the outside and
disrupting the Hollywood model and the
kids are just a side uh yeah I want that
news anchor who was like it's not as
much of a crisis as you think did you
give your fourth reason yet already or
yeah fourth is just a combination of the
three they're all in it they're all evil
they're all part of the cartels that's
the one the internet but but I don't
even think it Sheamus uh Coughlin has a
cartoon on freedom tunes that makes the
joke perfectly okay I'm gonna spoil it
for you guys because I need to make the
point but it's two Hollywood guys being
like oh this sound of Freedom you know
what is going on with this it's it's
succeeding they'll never change my mind
they go to see the film they're crying
and weeping as they watch it and they're
like and as they're leaving they're like
I never knew the suffering and
everything they went through
to bring us the children uh you get the
point uh we talk about how they're upset
because of The Gatekeepers and they're
mad that you guys are basically taken
over
but I think there's a component of we've
known for a long time because there's
the I think both quarries Corey Haim and
Corey Feldman did they both come out and
talk about it I think so I mean Feldman
definitely is vocally yeah and and then
you get you know Elijah Elijah Woods
talked about this but then you also have
just the general abuse of you know we
all know the story of Harvey and
everything he did I have I have a I have
a friend that lives in LA and she's been
in this world for a long time and when
Harvey finally went in she was just like
we've known this for forever it was
everybody's known Seth mixes everybody
knew Seth MacFarlane made the joke on
some award show then then you also have
Stewie Griffin in an episode of Family
Guy running through the mall saying help
help I've escaped Kevin Spacey's
basement
like people in Hollywood know what's
going on there so I'm gonna I'm gonna
say
the tribal partisan thing I think makes
sense because we've had people come on
and sit at the studio like the cultural
for instance an outright defend books we
have these books here where they're
showing graphic images of adult
activities to kids and say it's a good
book and I'm just like that's the most
insane thing ever like have you no
principles they don't but I really do
think Hollywood's got pedos who are
really pissed off that you guys put out
a film I think
I really do think that one of the
reasons Disney did not want to run this
is because there's high up people who
are like the last thing we want is
people focusing on this as a cultural
issue there's no reason for Disney not
to publish this film they had it it was
basically free they had bought it
already they could have put it straight
to DVD or put it on Amazon and made a
couple hundred thousand dollars
overnight but they decided to shut it
down something doesn't add up with that
because if the question was gatekeeping
they could have just put it on Amazon
they could have put it on Disney plus
hey here's another offering but for some
reason they said no one should see this
movie that's weird and then we we talked
about with with you know well we had Tim
here and uh Eduardo uh Edward or Edwardo
and Tim Ballard when we had him here he
was mentioning that there was going to
be a companion documentary that they
were they were supposed to make and it
was because they didn't want to do that
they released the rights to the film so
Disney's looking at it like we're gonna
have to release this film because of a
contract
and we're gonna have to make a
documentary about it
I think there are people who are high up
who have certain predilections who are
like we don't want two films so what's
what's your win scenario
pass it off so just the film comes out
hope it fails and don't make the
documentary your worst case scenarios
you have to make the documentary and the
film comes out so they actually are
looking at it like
you know we we we may lose this but we
don't take as much collateral damage in
terms of of their of their predilections
and what they don't want people talking
about I think it's possible
um I want to give
some benefit of the doubt that maybe
they just thought this isn't a brand fit
a brand fit uh I don't have you guys are
so nice
technically you're right I have every
reason to hate Disney I I
they made my life miserable for four and
a half years
um but the but there is I I think I'd
like to leave that open uh yeah I think
they are against against child
trafficking yeah kind of an interesting
brand to have I just Matt Kibby I was
talking to him the other day and he's he
said maybe it's like Baptist and
Bootleggers where you've got the one
side they're kind of almost like a
collaboration happening without them
even realizing that they're
collaborating one's actually against it
and one's for it but they're actually
making it happen together and he's like
that kind of reminds him of that in some
ways there's a parallel there I got I
got it pulled up right here law order
svu's been on the air for 24 years it is
one of the most popular television shows
of all time
so there's two points we made there why
Disney would look at a well-made movie
which they had already and could just
literally upload to Disney plus and be
like have a nice day
they have that they could release it
allowing them to be in a similar space
people liked the show clearly why would
they not do it did they oh we can answer
I have a question I have a follow-up
question so we were talking to John
Irwin because he said this movie came
across his desk at Lionsgate and um and
he was pushing for it he was pushing for
it he said he saw the potential for the
movie but he said all the people that we
launched through
they are the Elite they are the Power
Players they are the taste makers and
the the leaders don't want to touch the
film
we didn't know how to get it out the
door he said they're all calling him now
being like yeah everybody's like why
didn't we take that but then he said
when I saw you guys got it I was like
that was the perfect match because Angel
has a direct connection to the people
and the people will care about this
issue and they will be able to rise it
to the level that the taste makers pay
attention to it and the leaders have to
pay attention to it and so that's
exactly what happened when Disney sold
it back or to you guys is it public how
much they sold it for they sold it
Tidwell they sold it I think they
released it to him didn't they Eduardo
released a number of what he's got into
the film it's 14 and a half million I
don't know the exact details okay the
rest of yeah
okay but roughly he up to 14 million he
paid to Disney to get it and maybe
Disney thought they weren't going to get
14 million putting it on Disney plus so
they're just better off unloading it for
a small dose cash I I don't want I just
I just can't speculate yeah yeah I say
what you're thinking yeah I wanna I
wanna pull up this video we have this
video Ian miles Chong posted it says
this is what's popular on tick tock
meanwhile in China kids are learning
about theoretical physics practical
Woodworking and astronomy on doyin which
is their their their version of right
yeah this video is disturbing it's on
par with the NPC girls you guys have
seen that stuff like ice cream so I just
saw it the other day and I was so
confused by it my wife and we watched it
like seven times and we're sitting there
going to bed and we're watching it over
and over again I'm like what are they
doing and by the end you and everyone
else
I won't let myself watch I want to play
this video I got to play this video it's
23 seconds and you'll get a general idea
I don't want to be too loud but here we
go
oh you want to hit the audio
yeah
I mean guys
for those that are just listening it is
a guy who's crying and screaming and
trying to stack uh nuts like uh Hardware
nuts yeah I don't know I don't think
those are lug nuts necessarily just
Hardware nuts and uh it's deranged yeah
it is absolutely deranged content I feel
it roll for a second longer he makes
this weird like yeah that's why he's
popular is that face and that sound and
stuff so this is what possessed this is
what your kids are watching you feel
your mind disorganized as you watch it
this is what so uh I'll throw it back to
you guys are you guys familiar with Elsa
gate
YouTube started promoting a whole bunch
of these videos of Elsa Spider-Man and
the Joker running around doing
Shenanigans it started devolving into
extremely psychotic content where there
were cartoons of children drinking out
of urinals and consuming feces like 2013
or something this is the algorithm at
the time
I think this was YouTube it was an
accident yeah YouTube just had an
algorithm that recommended what got
clicked the most didn't really think
about it and it was being exploited and
people were just doing keyword searches
and then making whatever was getting the
most clicks and it turned into this
nightmare scenario I think with Tick
Tock you look at this video pull this
clip back up so people I want people who
are watching to see this guy's face
Tick Tock is promoting this stuff
because I think they figured out hey
Elsa gate is destroying the fabric of
the United States and the West because
the children who watch that are going to
have psychological problems and Trauma
later in life this is very much the same
thing as are the NPC girls there were
already stories about uh first young
girls facing extreme depression because
of Instagram but now you have stories of
young girls developing Tourette's
Syndrome because they would watch a
popular influencer with Tourette's start
imitating the person and then start
developing involuntary ticks in their
communication style because this is
Social Development for young people
I think Tick Tock is my personal opinion
promotes this stuff in the algorithm
because it is gutting and destroying the
fabric of our of our young people
this is another reason why I think it's
so extremely important one you guys
share
tell your friends to go see movies like
sound of freedom but all the other stuff
that that angel Studios has coming out
you've got uh what's that new there's
another movie you've got coming out uh
you've got Cabrini Cabrini yes I think
the shift is coming out in December it
really looks really good there's a
there's a there's one coming out in
October called after death oh cool dude
yeah the looks good this is awesome
I really want to see Cabrini that
trailer looks really amazing John
Lithgow is in it yes yeah and it's the
same director as Sandra Freedom oh and
it's his best work yet it looks really
my wife my wife and I screened it and my
wife came away and she said top five
movie of all time for me wow my
daughters that's their favorite movie
too wow that's amazing yeah you know uh
once once we have screeners we'll let
you right on right but I I don't wanna I
don't want to watch a screen or I watch
in theaters that's right yeah okay yeah
all right yeah so like get you in the
theater when it's time I don't I don't
know if it's supposed to be a secret
ever what sound of Freedom you know
someone reached out to me and said like
hey we got a screener we want you to see
the film I was like I'm going to
theaters man yeah I like I like you that
that's so much better yeah but that's
the theaters experience yeah especially
there with your friends and afterwards
we're walking out we're talking about
the parts we liked and not just that the
theater is this it's a it's a communal
experience you everybody goes in there
there's you guys know who Andrew
Peterson is who wrote The Wing feather
Saga uh amazing author from Nashville
musician pretty pretty big name but he
uh he he has a Blog called the rabbit
room and on that blog they published
it's a group of people that write on it
they wrote a blog post called the
sacrament of Cinema
and in it explains and this is what
shifted my gears on why movie theaters
are hanging on and why I think that they
have a bright future
is
he compares the the sacrament when you
go to church and you let go of
everything and you get into the exact
same experience as everybody around you
and you focus on this one thing which
represents Jesus Christ and you focus
focus focus and you you you take the
sacrament when you go to the theater
you're surrendering all your screens all
the social media and you're allowing
yourself to be enveloped in an
experience that director built for you
and crafted for you
and then immerse yourself and there's no
pause button and you're all together and
so you have this incredible experience
and it can be it can be life-changing
and I think that people are hungry to
get away from the social screens
and that the easiest most simple way to
do that is to head to the cinema and
shut it all down shut everything down
and it's healthy for us right now
where we're over stimulated so it almost
sounds weird because it used to be the
stimulation spot but this is actually I
think it's a way to shut things off I do
too the good news is so when we look at
this video and this guy is screeching
and making nonsense content which is
going to traumatize kids they're going
to grow up and they will imitate are
they going to be building spaceships are
they gonna be astronauts are they going
to be even race car drivers no they're
going to be saying insane things or
acting like NPCs and saying ice cream so
good but we're winning one obviously you
guys are here we're talking about angel
Studios all the projects you have but
along with this story is Dylan Mulvaney
announcing a stepping back from
producing content because only 50 of
Americans like me Dylan says and so
Mulvaney will be slowing down content
this is what happens when people speak
up for what they believe in when they
say uh rather sternly but politely don't
mulvani has bad content which is bad for
kids promoting alcohol to kids you know
people want to talk about gender
ideology I'm like absolutely but also
this the the Scandal starts with Dylan
promoting booze to children on Tick Tock
like let's that was the whole thing
grabbing all the beer cans cracking them
open and being like March Madness drink
beer and the average audience of tick
tock is under 21. these these are not
good things so when we see this stuff we
complain about Tick Tock yes there are
issues with a lot of people using the
platform Tick Tock banned us for
instance for no reason little sour
grapes there I suppose for no reason
we're removed we can't even express our
opinions but I think this is what leads
me to believe ultimately they're trying
to influence young people in ways that
destroy their lives when we look at
sound of Freedom when we look at I mean
Angel Studios you guys are slaying it
it's crazy the expansive growth we may
not have control of all the institutions
I have people say how can you claim
we're winning if Hollywood is owned by
the left if television is owned by the
left I'm like theaters one of my points
was theaters are not owned by the left
but my what I'm saying is uh winning
doesn't mean owning everything winning
doesn't mean you won right winning means
you are gaining the territory in the
conflict that's right and we are winning
that's right what you said about the
theater is so true it's it's epically
true it's been true for thousands of
years Beyond like Cinema's relatively
new aspect of theater but the theater
since the Greeks
it's a local thing it's not a global
thing people vibrate together in the
local community that's the ticket I had
a dude when I saw sound of freedom on my
to my left it was like breathing super
heavy he wasn't very healthy I was
drinking his diet coke or whatever he's
drinking but it like I have love for
that man it made that experience like
unique it was it was in my ear and it
was a little distracting but at the same
time I'll never forget it I'll remember
that forever that moment and I love that
guy I just remember that guy it was cool
to be there with them or or the fact
that I think it's it's I mean we might
be seeing as much as 10 of showings of
sound of Freedom having standing
ovations
and there there's showings where people
complete strange strangers hug each
other yes and this isn't an uncommon
report I think also you can't have that
at home yeah since covid has basically
died down the madness around covet
people want to go out and socialize
again and the cinema is the place yes
I'll say yeah I gotta say it every time
like the first the intro of of sound of
freedom is just so good oh yeah man it's
it's remarkable to me that they walked
away from that that they're like how do
you how do you not watch that and be
like wow this is an amazing film yeah
it's the intro just the intro man yeah
really well done we had a super chat
from earlier someone suggested that you
guys do or somebody does a movie about
the Statue of Liberty that story about
the Statue of Liberty that would be
really fun that'd be cool we are working
right now probably the first piece of it
will be done next year Jordan should be
talking about this part Founders yeah
yeah we're building a series on the
founding of America and trying to build
an entire this is so style yes this is
so undertone old Game of Thrones with
Memorial Compass but yeah of course
but this is such an undertold story
think about how many movies you know the
Patriot and then you know like a
bazillion documentaries dude the Patriot
is like John's favorite movies of all
time the Patriot is such a good yeah
John Adams in The Patriot that's about
you know that and there's that music
only 1776 that was pretty good in the UK
they complained but there's another
depiction of the British and The Patriot
because you get the bad guy like killing
children and they're like oh how dare
you it's not anti-british
anti-white Colonial you know what I mean
like go out there and make your own Pro
British movie I think it's interesting
because I I watched Patriot probably way
after everyone else but after it you're
like yeah let's hang an American flag
like this is great like you I I feel
like there is something really positive
out of walking out of theater and being
like I feel empowered to do something I
think sound of Freedom has that effect
for a lot of people even just be more
conscious of how they can serve their
local community but like the Patriot
makes you want to be like yeah it's a
good country this is cool stuff like
yeah I think that is sort of uh along
with the moral hunger and Society some
some way to feed that because videos
like this Tick Tock of this guy
screaming like that's the equivalent of
like fake chemical sugar that we're
feeding to our young people you need to
give them more substantial content for
them to to feed their minds their
emotions their souls things like that if
you have them on the app where there's
nothing nutritious so to speak there
then of course they wither away this
stuff's junk food this stuff's junk food
you know what that is really interesting
you bring up the Patriot and that was
made by an immigrant right uh Alejandra
was an immigrant Frank Capra who made a
ton of Americana right that uh It's a
Wonderful Life and
um uh Mr Smith Goes to Washington all
these films that helped Define our
country made by immigrants and um so
that's what I love about
um the cinema is that it's all about
uniting around an idea rather than
partisanship or or country lines it's
just about uniting around an idea well
and I think it's interesting too because
this new study came out saying they're
like only 18 of Young Americans consider
the themselves like very patriotic which
is sort of strange but when we saw uh
periods and no one quote me on the data
here but when we saw periods of high
patriotism it's when we're in Conflict
when we have to pull together with
people that we don't know who live in
our country we feel bonded that way and
to your point like I think at least in
my experience like a first generation
American immigrants choose to be here
and they realize often why they have
they have a decision there's a choice
right there's there's sort of an act of
love in that choice and I think that in
some way makes it easier to be clear
about what you have when you're born
into something it sometimes becomes easy
to be like math not that great because
you don't have anything to compare it to
right that's right I was in I was in
Poland and my wife and I we went to a
communist Museum they have a bunch of
them and I was reading I was just
amazing all the artifacts and everything
from the USSR that were there and these
Stalin statues and Lenin statues and
um and then I get out and I'm looking at
Google reviews
and there's all these Americans writing
these one star reviews and they're just
like uh it it makes communism look
really bad
they're like they need to they need to
get rid of their bias towards this I'm
just like what no these are the people
who like the people who made this Museum
are alive now and they lived through it
and anyway so it's just it they forget
uh they do it you're only a generation
away from from Freedom being gone yeah
yeah yeah we need to preserve the uh I
think about that when it comes to the
transgender movement and just
transgenderism in general if we could
somehow make a movie that shows someone
like going through it and you can really
empathize with the person struggling
with their own gender and then you can
kind of see it from the outside of
what's happening to them and why they're
going through it that it could remind
people in 20 years like it's okay to be
you like you can you know just to give
give young people hope that like if
you're feeling weird like there's a way
to okay weird yeah yeah and if we don't
tell the story we won't it won't be
remembered why it happened in the first
place and then we're doomed to repeat
this these cycles of like lack of faith
or lack of love for self so I would love
to make a movie about that I would even
love to play that character for honest
kids kids need you could do a great job
with that Ian
kids need stories where they will look
up to people yeah so that they they want
to emulate something you know I read
these stories online uh there's these uh
they're these memes where guys like I
have a kid he's kind of dumb he's five
and then one day I saw him running
around and he said I'm Spider-Man I'm
Spider-Man or something like that and
I'm like yeah the kids saw a movie where
the main character the good guy
Spider-Man is doing these heroic things
and then the kid imitates that you give
positive reinforce and say these are the
people we like these are the stories of
heroism right now what's happening is
we've had this period where there's a
lot of woke movies that have no clear
plot the the main characters are bad
guys like even if you look at uh Captain
Marvel's a good example there's this
really great video breakdown of Captain
America versus Captain Marvel Captain
America sacrifices himself for his
country he desperately tries to serve
his Nation even though he's not fit to
do so he's willing to jump on a grenade
to save people Captain Marvel's starts
off with her robbing a guy for his
clothes right and so and we're so and
because the guys on a motorcycle and he
goes you should smile and then she looks
at him and then robs him like apparently
they're they're playing this truck that
women should be empowered by stealing
for like she's the bad guy they tried
defending it saying well yeah you know
she changes later on and I'm like if
kids watch that and they look up to
someone who is mean nasty and entitled
they're going to grow up thinking that's
the way to be and we don't want them
you're gonna love Cabrini because
Cabrini is the story of a woman
is a Superhero by being a woman
and she unapologetically
unapologetically she's in a battle
against the mayor of New York
trying to figure out how to help the
poor and she's a Catholic nun and she's
a Catholic nun but she's an entrepreneur
who happens to happens to be a Catholic
nun yes what year today please it's 18
18 well she was born in 50
5600 late 1800s so she but it's just
this beautiful story of a woman being
powerful because she's a woman
and I am
I I think that what what we're seeing is
that people are sick and tired of
nihilistic movies yeah every single
movie ends with everybody's bad
but you get to the end of a series that
you liked and they just end with
everybody sucks everybody's bad
everybody everybody's complicated every
well complicated's fine
but there's no like true like good evil
black white hero like that that's just
missing right now ever it's just they're
sick of nihilism
and uh we're trying to offer antidote to
that is that you know stories they
amplify like but go ahead oh is this
when you're talking about Francis Xavier
Cabrini the woman the Italian-American
Saint yes it's powerful when first first
American Saint not
she's the very first person man or woman
are there more are there other ones now
yeah yeah oh cool yeah I had a question
um basically you said that you watched
you and your wife Jeff watch that weird
Tick Tock NPC seven times yeah and like
it's junk food you also mentioned how
it's like Jungkook did you feel like
gross after did you feel weird
afterwards because you was talking about
like discombobulates the soul or
whatever however you oh I said I feel my
mind disorganized as I'm watching it
yeah straight up junk food did you feel
it happening as you were walking because
I've had to shut that video off it's
like brain junk food yeah it's just it's
just like I I don't I think Tick Tock
just in general is brain junk food but
you know I think it's more like this
right it's like drugs oh yeah yeah I
guess you were talking about how movies
are complicated characters become
complicated and that that's kind of a
problem but you were saying it's okay
like complications okay I wonder about
that because
I think we do need like to reorient
people you know the reason I mention
that is because one of the reviewers of
sound of Freedom was was pointing out
how they wish that the character Tim
Ballard was more complicated but it just
happens to be a true story and Alejandro
and rodbar they wrote it the best they
could based off the stories and what
they knew about Tim Ballard and what
they knew about Tim and um and they
wanted something more complex
um and uh but clearly audiences just
want someone to go and fight
evil they want to see somebody fight
evil and know that that can happen and
it's giving people courage and when when
somebody sees someone else like if
someone sees Cabrini do something
someone sees Tim Ballard do something
they say wait a second
that that wakes up something inside of
me
yeah because you nobody's perfect like
right James probably gotten into
arguments with his wife but we don't
want to make people listen to it well
and he he actually tells the story
because in in the film she says to him
you quit your job and you go and rescue
those kids
he said the real story was he called her
and said
um
honey I have a chance to rescue some
kids the only way I can do it is if I
quit my job we've got six kids at home
you know obviously trying to talk around
he was trying to talk talk her out about
himself out of it and then she said I
hope I quote this correctly but she said
essentially
can can you rescue the kids if you stay
and he says yes I think I can and she
said then you need to quit your job and
go do that and he said no no no no no
you're crazy we'll lose our pension all
this stuff will happen don't come home
until you rescue those and she says you
don't come home until you rest of those
kids and then he he kept fighting it and
then he says I was kind of a coward and
then she finally said I will not
jeopardize my salvation by you not
rescuing those kids so that was the real
story right that that was but Alejandro
wanted to have the hero be the hero but
he was sitting there like
I don't have any support from the state
which means maybe I've got like a 50 50
chance that you that you become a widow
yeah that's kind of how he was feeling
whether or not that's without support I
mean yeah if you don't have support if
things go wrong you're gambling you know
we were we ended up having support of
the Colombian government by the end but
when he made that decision he had no
support we were listening to uh we
listened to a lot of classic rock and
all older songs and we're hanging out
downstairs we're also uh you know we
watch some older movies and I'm just
like where where are the modern
masterpieces you know the everything's
formulaic and I think it's probably fair
to say I didn't grow up in the 60s or
70s they probably had their formula in
garbage music all the same yeah and we
only remember the greatest works and
stuff like that but man I we're really
in need of a movie that will resonate
throughout Generations we need to get
away from this formulaic stuff you know
look superhero movies are entertaining
I'll go see them but sound of Freedom
was was meaning we need movies like that
even Groundhog Day right Groundhog Day
seems simple comedy but it's so so
powerful so right yeah like you walk
away from you want to be a better person
yeah but it's fun you know it's like
interesting it's an interesting idea
yeah well the song the system has gutted
out the the place where people can play
and take risks they've gone to tent
poles they've that's where they can
invest the money that's the way that
they know how to make the cinemas work
and that's the way they keep the
competition out so nobody can get in and
and play with risky storytelling and uh
the angel model has opened that door
again yep I think that door is wide open
now yeah is it because you guys that now
have contacts I'm still a little foggy
on the whole process so you I mean I
know you have 100 000 investors that
pick the thing they'll fund the thing
and then we can predict the Rotten
Tomatoes audience score based off the
skills oh nice and then in addition to
that
um we have
yeah the the
um
the the print and advertising marketing
budget normally comes from a bank or
from a big Studio they write one check
when we're getting the checks from seven
thousand ten thousand people
um it's the smartest marketing funds
that have ever been spent in Hollywood
because all those people bring their
family and friends they talk about it
and so it becomes a movement it becomes
something where people uh have to be
part of it
um and additionally like
with our history of selling products and
making them household names we had this
moment click where we realized that
selling seats is no different than
selling squatty potties and squatty
potties by the way work
yes they do really what's what's the
movie that you guys coming out you said
one October I think October is after
death after death yes after death
because I want to go see it what's that
thing about as a trailer out um I can
text you the trailer oh yeah why don't
Jordan why don't you get it yeah Jordan
we haven't talked to you much on the
show we'll get you the trailer make your
younger brother do things in the
background over here I'll give you my
number after the show Jordan but if I
mean I think that would be okay just
showing a preview of if you guys just
want to show a rough cut of the trailer
is it on YouTube no it's no it's nowhere
let's just do it how do we do it Jordan
hook it up it's not actually out yet
this won't be the final trailer this is
a draft of the trailer yeah cool but now
we're yeah let's let's do it oh wow
sneak sneak preview Tim cast IRL viewers
well they send it over can I say yeah
where are we sending it with uh Jordan
figure it out maybe it was Surge yeah I
think it was a surge and get to him
so having
um so there's six brothers so they're
nine in our family six boys and three
girls and
um
the
so in the beginning there were some
struggles figuring out how to work
together but after we nailed it and
after we figured it out it's it feels
providential how the skill sets of our
family complement each other and it just
so happens that there have been many
other companies that have been very
successful that are brothers the Disney
brothers or family too yeah Roy Roy and
Walt uh you've got the Warner Brothers
the Koch brothers the Nolan Brothers
You've Got
um the musk Brothers yeah
um and uh and so when family can figure
out how to work together well there's
power in that and so it's really worked
out well for us and three of you are
involved in a cousin you said or all six
of the brothers so four of us and a
cousin started this company uh only
three of us work here full-time we have
another brother who is the showrunner
for Tuttle twins oh cool uh we have an a
brother who is is um
leads the Consulting agency and then
another brother who ended up being the
operator over at vid Angel when it got
sold like the guy who's the CEO of it
Angel uh hired another brother to do
that that's interesting so if you have
more jobs you just enlist the rest of
your brother that sounds supernap
artistic but no maybe it's nice because
you guys know each other I mean the
other one is the Ringling Brothers and
there were like 400 of I mean by that I
mean I think they were like eight
Ringling Brothers and they each did
different things and had different skill
sets and that was ultimately if you're
just kind of cast from the right die
um for us the casting comes from just
being Farm Boys in Idaho uh and just a
farm family that's where you guys grew
up in Idaho yeah and Jordan Jordan over
here in the background he he left after
co-founding with us he left for a while
and he started another company called
Cove and grew it to like 100 million
dollar company and then it ended up
being our like other team members and
our board who decided to hire him back
because we we know we didn't feel like
we could make that decision and they
hired him back and it's been great to
have like he's been like filled out the
team and helped the team so much so it's
definitely not nepotistic in our unless
that can be defined in a good way I'm
not trying to imply it's just
interesting because some people feel
like you can't work with your spouse you
can't work with your siblings uh but
obviously and it is it's really hard to
work with family members but when you
can make it work something happens that
uh other co-workers say uh you guys need
to just like talk more because you have
this like non-verbal communication
happening where you know what's
happening with each other yeah and it
makes it a little harder they're like
the three brothers that are operating in
the company you guys are like are
together like our CEO you're like the
Elon Musk the three of you together yeah
and then the rest of us have to figure
out what you guys are actually thinking
because you're you you don't you don't
need to communicate as clearly because
we don't yeah and and it works really
really well we get we get uh the the
um everybody else just has to figure out
how to
what we're thinking yeah and so when you
started the company you were all in Utah
is there a benefit for the film because
there are certain states that are sort
of cultivating film industries from what
I understand is Utah one of them
so uh Provo actually was one of the one
of the
um it's a very good capitals of media
like the number of YouTubers that were
in Provo when we first started this
company it was like the fourth in the
world yeah yeah well because they were
from what I understand they LED like
sort of Lifestyle vlogging yeah and and
there's you know the piano guys are from
Utah Devin Supertramp
um uh Lindsey Stirling Lindsay Sterling
so there were a ton of views but not
just that it's it's a we Utah is a very
strong ad market so advertising agencies
are very very strong in Utah and we have
a a very very good Tech market and so
Angel studios are core competencies our
technology
and marketing that is what we're very
very good at and when we work with
amazing filmmakers to get their content
to go Global so I think we can try and
play it
um I don't know how it's gonna look do
you want to switch over and see what it
looks like if you just go full screen uh
we can't
but uh that's fine if it can't I think
there's something more screen this way
so
yeah I don't know if we can even do that
it should
should be fine yeah all right well I
always ruining that yeah maybe maybe
switch to the uh just just yes
yeah I don't know the move screen full
screen yeah go back to the other one and
we'll just play it yeah it looks bigger
there
so this is a rough cut
I got you at school it was 1969. a
beautiful day to fly
we were about
when I started noticing that something
was wrong
engine failure
trees were filling our windshield
we hit that Dome boom
I found myself above the crash site
and while I'm processing what I'm
looking at I could see a pilot
and this is me
no two near-death experiences are the
same
I don't know
I don't know if the trailer truck kept
me had on
but they typically occur in a very
consistent process we began to go down
the river
my boat became
the first thing that happens is called
an out-of-body experience and they come
to a place of exquisite beauty they very
commonly see a light
deceased relatives come to meet them the
first person I saw was my grandfather
now I'm traveling like a rocket ship
straight upwards and with that
oh my God I'm alive
but not every near-death experience is a
good one
23 had hellish experiences I saw a black
tunnel economy just falling I wasn't in
fear I was a terror it was just darkness
put me back
I don't belong here
I heard a voice before I woke up you
still have a purpose on Earth I was very
skeptical I never felt alive
I love it
more alive I had full brain recordings
from a dying human brain even though
they were unconscious they were able to
give corroborative evidence
she's describing stuff that she just
shouldn't know this ain't right who
can't be mystified by that question what
happens after you die
this really does show that there is life
after death
foreign
oh man that looks awesome yeah I got
chills when the hellish scene happened
in the wow that's really well made it's
an impressive The Guild The Guild picked
this Angel Guild picked this and it just
popped out you know getting 60
filmmakers a week in the guild was just
like boom this is this is one of them
and um and we're going with October
because
The Day of the Dead is in October so
that sounds fun
yeah it sounds fun it's a good good
juxta's position it's like narrative
documentary like
it's so cinematic are all the theater is
going to be like we gotta pick up this
movie because sound of freedom is so
good this will probably be a smaller
release then for sure it's a smaller
release this is a this is a littler like
there'll be enough theaters that people
can find it but it will be it will be
more similar to his own no my theater
has it yeah more more similar to his
that's gonna be fun for Halloween that's
good do you feel pressure now that like
sound of freedom is so big you're like
well what do we do next well I think
Cabrini is going to be bigger than that
level and then we've got a one coming in
2025 called David
and it's a 60 million dollar animated
musical because what King David and his
based on like old school Disney style
it's like the way it used to be yeah
like like uh it's a bunch of people from
the
Pixar's team that have come together
winning a culture War man but this this
is awesome because most musicals
everybody just breaks out music for no
reason and in David King David was a
musician and he was called into salt
King Saul to actually sing to bring down
his nerves or whatever it was it sounds
like a emotional issue for King solid
schizophrenia or something when you read
it but he he brings down his nerves
because he's such a and he wrote the
entire like most of the book of Psalms
which he's just an incredible artist so
the music's all motivated throughout the
entire yeah animated musical because
David's a musician so it's a very
interesting take and I think it's going
to be huge I wanted you guys said that
this trailer it was just watched as a
rough cut so what would be an example of
how that would change as you're
finalizing trailer like technically
um there's there's tweaks for messaging
mostly the the the audios mostly there
it won't it's not sweetened yet or
balanced so maybe that didn't turn out
as well online but you got a sneak peek
it's it's a live stream
um but the and then you've got different
messaging things where there's like
should we put
um like one of the debates was does the
dark stuff
should the dark stuff be so prominent in
the trailer or is that going to put some
people off no and we're trying to figure
out if that and and my my wife responded
the same way she's like that's the most
likely that's intriguing like I've never
seen anybody first off these these kind
of stories are very common I've had like
neighbors that have had these type of
experiences
but they're also
spread out
and not ever no one's ever gone through
and just like told them in a really good
way that's that's scientific as well as
good storytelling and um this this film
I read a book about uh
people call them near-death experiences
but the stories are actually death
experiences that's right every single
one of these they're dead right people
who they are legally they're they're
like doctors this is uh said they're
dead 20 19 years ago I I someone someone
lent me a book and I was raiding this
guy collected a bunch of stories of all
these different people who had different
totally and dramatically different means
of dying some they were sick and they
were on their deathbed in the hospital
some were in car accidents some people
slip fell hit their head things like
this and then they all described very
very similar things much like what was
actually in that trailer how they
described a place of beauty or a light
and things like this uh I want to ask
one last question before we go super
chats video games
you guys go to any video video games so
we experimented with a um with
um with Roblox with uh feathers I think
Wing feather Saga will eventually be a
really good video game yeah it was built
in Roblox no no it's built in the wing
feather song is really interesting
because they animated it and they built
specific kind of Animation if you look
up Wing feather Saga trailer
um the
this animation is designed it will
remind you it came before
um put some Puss and Boots the new one
yeah but it has some of the similarities
Puss in Boots These Guys pioneered this
type of animation and they used uh epics
um the uh Unreal Engine Unreal Engine
and they they designed an entire way to
animate with Unreal Engine which means
that it's easy to bring it into a video
game yeah it's built to be able to make
a video game yeah the future I think
movies and video games are kind of
coming together where you can become the
character in the movie yeah and
experience it from different
perspectives yeah I got one last
question for you Tim would you let them
hook your brain and body up to a
recording machine perfect resolution
recording and then let them kill you and
bring you back to life no wow
just wondering that's the that's part
two
I wonder if that constitutes suicide
if they kill you without your consent
well no I mean if you choose
but but if you if you choose to go to a
lab and they say we're going to induce
death and then bring you back yeah would
that be suicide as long as you're in
Canada it's fine but I'm I'm speaking
spiritually and morally are you now
condemned to hell for the mortal sin of
killing yourself and if they fail to
bring you back did they murder you
that's a good question yeah I would
assume that people part two of after
death I like it but the video game stuff
would be cool
still happening one of the one of the uh
final fan I played Final Fantasy 16
I thought it was not that good uh some
people are saying it's so great I'm like
uh Horizon The Horizon series is
actually really really good I don't know
if you guys have played it but it's it's
it's it's it's great storytelling long
story short
uh guy invents self-replicating war
machines
one of them gets one a company that
contracts a group of these machines gets
locked out the machine starts
self-replicating faster and faster the
right replication overwhelms human
capabilities to stop it Planet gets
destroyed the last ditch effort is to
build a terraforming system on Earth so
the game takes place in the future after
civilizations collapsed and you're
fighting these gigantic machines and
then you later learn those machines or
actually terraforming the planet some
problem happens chaos conflict Etc but
it's cool to to you know stories like
that some people don't like it I like it
although the uh The Forbidden West is
irritatingly woke in that all the bad
guys are dudes and all of the heroic uh
heroic generals of the good guys are
women and it's just like at a certain
point come on man you know and and they
make you fight women all the time and
I'm like it is kind of weird that in
this game you go around just mercilessly
beating women but they wanted they
wanted all of these fighters to be like
very prominently female and I'm like
it's just a game where you go around
beating women you know like even if
they're gonna do it 50 50 you'd have
some guys here and some guys there it's
like
mostly women you know so but you know
video games are cool let's go to super
chats if you haven't already would you
kindly smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share this show with
your friends and head over to
timcast.com become a member to support
our work directly and we're gonna have a
members only uncensored show where you
as members can call in and talk to us
and our guests and ask questions that's
the most fun part of the night
but for now we will read your super
chats I'm not your buddy guy says I've
come to the conclusion that Western
intelligence agencies specifically
American have grown beyond their scope
and are more of a problem than solution
do we dissolve or reform them if so how
you vote for Donald Trump and then you
defund and dissolve or Vivek
said he'd do it all right be his press
secretaries which one will really do it
though that's the question ah the vague
because I I like Vivek I like RFK uh I I
I mean I couldn't vote for Trump because
he was for the lockdowns like I just and
his spirit for the lockdowns
he wasn't against them he was against
him he's said he said we shouldn't do
this it should be by choice but I don't
have the authority and then I don't
think he said that articulately he was
like I can't do it it's the governors
they could do they're doing their thing
yeah he was he was four in the beginning
yeah so for me that's where that's where
he loses me but I I really like um Vivek
Vivek and I like uh I like RFK Jr I
think Vivek is how it is
dude he's legit that guy's awesome we
just interviewed him last week he's he's
sharp he's the best guy running in my
opinion but uh
Trump's I'm a realist
so and he didn't know to pay a job so
what's the point the vague's ability to
win we can be idealists during the
primaries idealistically I'd love to see
the vague win realistically I think he
gets a cabinet position in the Trump
Administration trumps the guy with the
gravitas to win he said that he wouldn't
take him to position because he's not
wired to take a number two position and
I just thought that was like a very
interesting very self-aware comment so
maybe he'll change it he wouldn't be
able to do it he said like some people
like would you see a vice president
Trump and it's like it's very difficult
to imagine a vice president
all right here we go Raymond g Stanley
Jr says Tim forget about Corn Pop he was
merely just a bad dude coconut and
monkey on the other hand are leading a
domestic terrorism campaign against
fellow crackheads and they'll only get
probation yeah this is a story out of
Seattle did you guys hear about this
IEDs were planted there's a shootout
there's a drug camp that went up in
Flames coconut I think was the leader a
second of command was monkey like this
is what's happening in these cities when
people absolve themselves of their
responsibilities and their civic duties
yep coconut running around setting fires
apparently there were people in a tent
doing drugs Fentanyl and then this guy
placed a bunch of IEDs all over the
place and just torched everything one
dude got like seriously burned and is in
like critical condition or something
story report
I'm Michael why haven't I heard about
this well I I my first thought was I've
been launching a movie yeah yeah I just
don't think the corporate press is going
to be like did you know that far left
extremists have implemented policies
resulting in gang Warfare in Seattle to
the point where forests like are being
set on fire and IEDs are being planted
and shootouts are happening and they're
assaulting people who are taking drugs
that are trafficked across the border
like yeah they just don't want to talk
about it
wow Steve McGee says if Biden said Corn
Pop is bad I'm going to assume he is
good well the conspiracy theory is That
Corn Pop caught Joe Biden touching kids
inappropriately and Joe Biden lied about
the story for you know brownie points or
whatever Corn Pop was a good dude right
you know Joe Biden's got that story it
was like the kids they'd rub my legs
look at hairy legs it's like what and
someone made a cartoon where Joe Biden's
in a pool and the kids are rubbing his
legs or whatever yeah maybe Corn Pop saw
him and was like stop touching these
kids you you freak and then Joe Biden
grabbed a rusty chain and was like
what'd you say to me
great story I mean look make a movie I
don't trust yeah I don't trust Joe
Biden's version of events I called him
messler and he got mad Corn Pop will
have his day
all right Coco medetta says the Tuttle
twins books are the best my kids love
them and I'm buying extra to give for
birthday gifts spread the Good News by
doing the same what is it I don't know
Tuttle twins yeah Tuttle twins is a
best-selling book series that sold I
think five or six million copies that
teach kids about the principles of
Liberty and economics and we've made a
TV series based on the book series I'm
wearing the Hat
um that's got this Grandma cubid who's
in a wheelchair and her wheelchair
happens to be an interdimensional time
traveling wheelchair and she takes her
twin grandkids that are half uh cube and
a half American and flies them around to
meet characters like Benjamin Franklin
or Harriet Tubman or
um uh Frederick bastier just all
inventors
entrepreneurs Educators it's it's in
it's halfway through season two right
now it's growing parabolically it's it's
it is a huge hit you can you can watch
it for free with your kids on Angel the
angel app or angel.com it's it's growing
it is
killer I know it's so good a lot of
parents who sell twins as part of their
homeschool curriculum because they
produce some some companion stuff so
it's interesting that you'd offer a TV
version it's the same same riding team
is doing this that wrote The Squatty
Potty ad so that tells you how funny
nice so this is it's a show it's a
cartoon show it's a cartoon series yeah
about 20 minutes per episode we are our
timeline for our coffee shop our first
Casper location may be this fall I'm
hoping we were planning on having it
open in the spring but uh we're in a
historic building so that brings up a
whole bunch of complications with what
we can do what we can use what we can't
use how long it's going to take to get
things up and running but the plan we
had and the reason why I want physical
space is one we want to have a thousand
locations all over the country the
general idea that I pitch is
mom's on her way to soccer practice the
kids she wants to get a cup of coffee
she walks in and orders it and while
she's waiting there are TV screens and
they're playing Crowder we can get two
total twins for that and one other side
better than that the the uh big idea
outside of the general idea is Saturday
morning cartoons where Saturdays at like
6 a.m We open early we invite families
to come with their kids we play content
that is wholesome approved and good for
the kids parents interact build
community with each other the kids meet
each other and play there will be a food
catering or something and then what's on
the TV it could be Tuttle twins it could
be uh what's the daily wire doing
chinchilla the one yeah yeah yeah so
getting getting supporting the parallel
economy but just having shows for kids
that are good educational wholesome all
at the same time we're not going to go
near any of the traditional stuff that I
grew up with because well they're going
to sue us into Oblivion and stuff like
that so we're going to support the
companies that support us and yeah
that's that's the plan it's like secular
church almost that's awesome that's
awesome and title twins is every bit as
high quality like
um think uh Rick and Morty but with the
moral compass
so one of the kids one of the twins is
drunk and uh
no it's it's it's it's solid it's good I
love their teaching economics to kids
that's just lit me up when I was in
first grade and then they just didn't
give it to me for the rest of my school
yeah we just did it we just did my
six-year-old comes up and and and
recounts these random facts about
Frederick Hyatt or they went and met
Milton Friedman learned about inflation
and my kids are like oh I saw inflation
at the grocery at the grocery store the
other day the thing I normally buy with
my money was more expensive than last
this is inflation and I know why yeah
and then they repeat the lines like
inflation kills a nation and then or or
this a couple weeks ago they did um the
they released the the the episode on
hard money and they talk about Bitcoin
and explain Bitcoin and they meet
Satoshi Nakamoto oh yeah and is he
wearing them that one's super viral it's
got like a pair it's got like a thing
with Elon Musk like blasting off with
those dogs in a row what is Satoshi like
a silhouette or something no his face
gets covered everything never you never
see anything but his eyes he's
explaining the whole entire like what
hard money is yeah so it's it's really
fun right on all right Hank fed says
building culture is a slow process that
means nothing if it doesn't change the
people in power or how the ones we vote
for present us anything we do can easily
be undone by the laws they pass
incorrect sir incorrect uh and I I
explained this uh uh after your Super
Chat to be fair you're super chatted and
then later in the show we were talking
about it but there are so many laws on
the books that do not get enforced
that's just it they can pass all the
laws they want if police don't enforce
it they're meaningless it becomes Civil
Disobedience essentially
cohabitation is illegal in West Virginia
a man and woman who are unmarried are
not allowed to live together okay that's
kind of crazy like no cop is going to
enforce that within that same law you
cannot be openly lewd or lascivious as
particularly with children yet they
still have lewd adult shows with kids at
these Pride events no cop will go near
it doesn't matter if the laws in the
book says you can't do it the culture in
that in in this is Shifting we got to
shift it back and say hey man leave
these kids alone
there's there's this in in episode six
of season one of Tuttle twins they cover
this issue just just looping that back
in is that there's a song that this guy
from Georgia who lives in a houseboat
that's he's parked in this boat for more
than 30 days and it's illegal and he
sings a whole song about everything's
illegal oh yeah it's amazing
anyway did you know that uh if you stop
at a yellow light that's illegal and if
you go through your life that's illegal
no
it's the interpretation of the officer
so they can they can give you a ticket
for either either way either way if you
slam your brakes on they can say it's
Reckless it's an abrupt stop could cause
an accident you're getting a fine if you
go through it they can say potentially
speeding or you know that they can make
up a reason I I uh disorderly conduct is
the easiest one every jurisdiction
effectively has disorderly conduct you
could be protesting holding up a sign
and they say take that sign down now and
you say I'm not doing anything wrong
disorderly conduct you're under arrest
everything's a resisting arrest too like
yeah there are tons of protesters who
have been arrested for resisting arrest
yeah how many felonies does the average
person committed a day I think it's
three yeah how can you like that's the
first yeah we have some friends who are
up in Idaho and they were singing
outside during covert They just won that
yeah they just got an award from Moscow
Idaho they got arrested in Moscow During
the covid period they went outside and
worshiped at a church in Moscow Idaho it
made it illegal and they went out and
sang outdoors and they were like
tackling them and arresting them and
they just got a huge award for uh it won
the case yeah they won the case all
right I'm not sure if it was or settled
they won or settled sevi Rose says thank
you sound of Freedom Angels Tech
question have you heard of sponsor block
I was reminded of it by your lawsuit
open source browser extension and a
database of user contributed timestamps
for skipping embedded advertising in
supported slash cracked players
cool there's a free open source browser
extension
what fandom says just got the post that
sound of freedom is coming to Tasmania
so Australia is getting it hyped to see
it yes it is that's right yep I think
you guys always said that uh it's going
International in a bunch of places yeah
go to angel.com blog and all the
announcements right there yeah it's
coming to all of Latin America on
October no August 31st August 31st and
then Brazil's in September I think yeah
September 21st and uh UK is September
1st so I think it's August 16th in
Australia are all the harman brothers
co-founders and Equity holders of Angel
Studios or are there like their other
investors other people there's four
brothers that co-founded out of the six
the co-founded Angel Studios but I think
do you have other investors like we have
because because we're owned by the by
the the community audience in the
community too we have ten thousand yeah
but outside of that was were there were
there like prominent individuals where
like we're going to pledge a large
amount of money to help you guys get off
the ground three VC funds yeah three or
four one of them actually their El their
LPS are from Max ago so that was
interesting that was the first fund that
invested yeah the their LPS are in
Mexico and then the most recent fund
that invested is called gigafund which
is one of the largest investors in
SpaceX oh yeah yeah gigafund yeah yeah
yeah they put that's Elon isn't it they
did 40 something million dollars they
put they put a lot of money they follow
elon's companies and uh wow wow yeah
because uh aren't they yeah they fund
they invest in companies that they
believe will change their their industry
over the next day they invested in you
guys yeah yes wow yeah are these guys
jumping up on their desks and doing the
Lindy Hop because of the success you're
having or happy right now fantastic
investment by the way we had a good one
we had a good board meeting last week
they're like guys we've got 130 million
dollars on this movie yeah so gigafund
yeah they've put in and their goal is
they just say any any company that's
going to change the world and that they
believe the founders will stick around
with it for a decade or two and part of
the settlement was that Jeffrey and I uh
put up our stock against
um the settlement to uh to move on Wow
how does that work you put up the stocks
it just means that means for 14 years
our stocks tied up we're in this for at
least 14 years if we if we if we filter
Disney stuff over the next 14 years they
could come after us for
for our stuff so you're really putting
your word yeah we're putting our our
livelihood livelihood on the line
Goldilocks production says I always hate
when people say Don't Fight Fire with
Fire that makes things worse has no one
heard how they fight forest fires they
use controlled Burns to fight them
fighting fire with fire
uh what what they'll do in in fields
you'll see if there's like brush fire
and stuff they'll actually burn a line
right and that stops the fire that's
kind of like uh an example would be like
if they're like sending kids to a
sexualized system and you're like yeah
that would be great if we could overly
sexualize every little kid and that's
like you burning a perimeter around the
idea so that they're like okay I'm not
gonna go that far so that'll be an idea
of like fire with fire I don't think in
that capacity I don't want to do that oh
that's how I think in the capacities
like those
Paul Morris says become alive start to
thrive
jm13sc says based not disgraced I was
thinking just like not woke not broke I
mean it doesn't it doesn't exemplify
making money though our goal
um
one if you want to change the world
capitalism is the best vehicle too good
at go make money on something that's
going to change the world like the only
way we're going to get sound to freedom
to every corner of the earth is if we
make it super economically profitable or
else it will never get there I just
can't
and and so that that's the first thing
the second thing that we try to focus on
is
um focus on what you're for
more than what you're against
if you focus on what you're for you'll
get further I think you get a quicker
start when you focus on what you're
against but if you focus on what you're
for you'll get a longer run
he is a good one El Rojo Grande says
reject woke trash and rake and drown in
cash
I'm still looking for a positive one you
gotta find the Rhythm a little bit but
it's pretty good reject woke trash and
he put rake slash drown so I think I
think drowning cash I like drowning cash
raking the cash oh that one's good too
that works reject the cult and you won't
go broke be based and cash awaits
there's really no good Rhymes no the
first one was good reject woke trash and
rake in the cash
well I'm looking for something get well
go broke That's a classic yeah it's hard
to compete with that but you know which
something Rhymes but really I guess the
idea is get will go broke also does mean
the inverse if you're not woke you will
not go broke you know it's getting well
which makes you go broke
uh Mike Z says the wing feather Saga is
amazing show and book series as a writer
myself I've been working on a book for a
number of years when my mother caught
wind of the series and showed me it I
now own the entire book series and I'm
Blown Away on the similarities thanks
Angels oh yeah and my my daughter who's
eight she she told me for years Frozen
has been she's like Elsa's my favorite
movie after watching the first season of
wing feather Saga she said and this is
after many years she said
Elsa is no longer my favorite movie oh
wow Wing feather sock is my favorite
movie we got a crowdfund that uh buddy
cop movie yeah me and Roseanne Ian Ian
and Roseanne's gonna be the police chief
I don't know if he knows that yet no I
haven't called him yet no give me a ring
buddy it's gonna be great man what's the
what's what's the conflict you know it's
like a I think we need to find
anti-gravity we need to recover the
anti-gravity Tech because someone's
trying to oh they're not cops that's
like secret agents yeah the idea of
buddy cop is just kind of a genre so
we'll just be like two partners but
buddy but it would be funny if you were
both like beat cops 100 no Gibson's like
I won't stand for it and then Roseanne's
like ah yes son of a I don't know
only Rosie can do do Rosie you know or
you know maybe a superhero film where
Ian has A Beat cop
is chasing a bad guy who breaks into a
graphene laboratory for sure and we're
doing graphing and then what you do is
it's not you know in Batman the Joker
falls into the Vata chemicals but in
this one it's Ian oh that's a good idea
and then me and Roseanne become enemies
but then at the end it's like oh I'm not
gonna spoil it no no because I'll become
kind of a creepo effort on the back yeah
but we there's tension after that you
know and so we've got to overcome the
tension I'm not gonna spoil the end
hopefully it works out oh oh speaking of
graphene yeah thanks sir
just holding it keeping it close
let's grab some more Super chats
gormall says I never believe in the
death penalty until The Merchant of
death was released some people do think
so evil the only way we can ensure they
don't do it again is death if they live
the chance of those evils still exist
and I don't disagree the problem is when
Kamala Harris walks up to you and says
this guy right here deserves death I'm
gonna be like yeah lady not happening I
don't trust you sorry yeah sorry
legitimately it's four percent the
studies show that four percent of death
penalty uh are accidents they don't get
the right person think of all the things
that you don't trust the state to do for
you so
right let's not add to the list
bureaucratized death is not it's not a
good thing you know and and the thing is
on the surface when you get a governor
you trust and he's like this guy
murdered kids he was convicted we're
gonna you know put him to death or
whatever
on the surface it's very much like we
get it yeah well and they do deserve
death people so the thing about abusing
kids especially this trafficking and
rape and all that stuff is it's worse
than murder I really do think so murder
takes a life but abusing children in
this way rips apart the fabric of human
civilization so it's like there's a
reason why Jesus was so like rapper
millstone around their neck and throw
them to the bottom that line from uh
from caviesel was so good he ad-libbed
it he ad-libbed it yeah so I didn't know
Jesus said that that's cool that's like
from the Bible
and that was for sure it was better the
millstone be wrapped around your neck
and thrown to the bottom of the ocean
then uh then hurt well it's it's like he
who would hurt God's children shall have
a millstone Caster on their neck and be
cast into the ocean or something of that
effect there's different translations of
it but the general idea yes but he he
went who would turn their children from
me or something like that yeah he went
total gangster right there you know like
the things they do to kids when those
kids grow up they hold those traumas and
it ripples out it rips out they act out
on other kids or they act out like most
most of child abuse is kid on kid now
and but as adults start it and they hit
a kid and then the kid goes and does it
to their peers but even beyond that a
kid who is abused who grows up and
struggles and can't hold a job and is
traumatized and just harmed yes it's
going to cause Ripple it destroys their
life and then all the kids they would
have had or do have are affected and
it's really hard to break those Chains
It's really hard people people listening
know that if you're the one who has to
break the chain that is a really hard
thing and it I I honestly think the only
way to do it is through Christ that's
that's the way you break the chain but
Chris W says Angel studios please create
an unwoke Cinematic Universe of fairy
tale remix
no I like the original content I have to
say I like that you guys are telling new
stories I think Cinematic Universe is is
is a good idea but the only one who's
ever pulled it off was Marvel and only
for 10 years because after infinity
people are getting sick of it we are
going to try to create a Cinematic
Universe around the founders that see
that's cool uh it's it's it's not I
don't think people are sick of cinematic
universes I think it's that they can't
do it here's how it works right no I
think people are sick of the of the fake
Hero Stories like makeup made up Hero
Stories that's what people are sick of
they love to have a universe of that
they can get into they made Iron Man or
actually it was the Hulk in 2008 I think
at the end there's an end credit scene
no I remembers first Hulk was yeah Hulk
was the first Marvel Studios film really
yes and uh at the end of it uh General
what's his face I don't remember his
name meets with Robert Downey Jr in a
restaurant and that's the it was
basically just
Iron Man's next then they made Iron Man
and that wasn't even the good Hulk right
that was no uh that was the the I I
think that was considered to be the
better Hulk film oh is it yeah it was
the one with Edward Norton I think yeah
is that the one in Brazil I don't know
maybe but uh so what's like it looks
like Iron Man was released like two
months before they were both in 2008
Iron Man was
um yeah May 2nd and then in June yeah
pretty sure it came out June 8th was
released in the US on June 13th in the
US sure that's what according to Marvel
Cinematic universe.fandom.com Wikipedia
yeah and IMDb
but it's a small discrepancy we just
loved that story because that they went
through bankruptcy at the same time when
they put you know when they started the
Cinematic Universe and so we were like
oh yeah yeah it was Iron Man I really I
thought it was the Hulk wow yeah how did
the Hulk get we're destroying Tim's
Universe right now but I do think that
the Hulk actually like the story
proceeded like like that's where the
story fell but uh but the the general
idea was they didn't actually make a
Cinematic Universe they were just
putting plugs for the next movie to get
people excited right but it effectively
connected all the films yeah and so then
they were like hey let's roll with this
yeah whereas DC was then like we're
gonna make a Cinematic Universe and they
just crammed a bunch of garbage into a
bunch of films and it was like this is
nonsense that's how it feels crammed
like it doesn't feel organic the way
that's what's happened to Marvel too now
though it feels it's starting to feel
more like DC
right C.S Cooper says I loved Wing
feather Saga I can't wait for the next
season also Freelancers I'm going to
pitch my novels and movie ideas to Angel
Studios feel like expanding to Australia
[Music]
what about uh another question do you
feel like I mean we have uh David's
coming from a South African uh filmmaker
they're in their entire studios in South
Africa the David movie
if that's as far as ways you can get
from where we're at what were you asking
Tim uh ripavers Eric July's coming yeah
wow yeah I want you guys you know make
yeah we we somebody can connect us yeah
make movies I follow Eric on Twitter but
I don't haven't connected with him yet I
don't come on Eric take one of it I'm
not super familiar with this comic book
series other than the massive success
he's had with it he has yeah and then
make a movie based on these characters
and take over the superhero genre away
from the weird stuff that's been going
on
what do we got we'll grab some more
Louis T says the best movies have been
from the 50s 60s Hollywood is so into
remakes that I think you could bring
back the best of the classics and in
some and make some winning Cinema we
seem to be out of movie ideas there's
gold in the past I I disagree I agree
that there's a lot of old great movies
but I'm just I'm over the remakes like
let's get some new culture and fuse into
the into the machine that's what people
are craving people God oh people think
that that uh that is that the Golden Age
of Cinema is behind us it's just because
the model got gutted and there wasn't a
path for real risk-taking and
storytelling and and we think that's
solved for the future the carbon age is
upon us yeah the diamond age maybe let's
create that the diamond diamond yeah
Platinum Platinum or Palladium
age cooler though palladium's hot that's
how you do cold fusion
more opal's kind of a big deal for a
while I like Opals I might have some
around here you were talking about and
then the price above will Spike I was
like this guy really knows
I was thinking of the the movie The Book
of Kells which was like an Irish
production and it was just new and
different and sort of based on uh from
what I know about it from uh Irish
mythology it's not just like and now
we're gonna tell Little Red Riding Hood
again which is a fantastic story if you
read to your children but there's just
more out there and I think being able to
give creators sort of a fresh take and a
fresh chance rather than rehashing the
same thing over and over again it would
be cool to see and I think that's
something you guys prioritize you need
to you got to give him a hero like a
just an epic flaw it makes the character
so good yeah I've never enjoyed the
Superman stuff because it's too perfect
which one was it where Superman almost
dies and I was like oh is he gonna kill
him and let his son be like because he
has a son now that's like half and half
and I was like oh wouldn't it be awesome
if they killed off Superman and then let
a more flawed version of Superman come
up afterwards and then they've just made
a good and DC didn't do that I thought
that would be kind of cool as if they
let him self-sacrifice
let his son who's now half human just
man yeah half man half human then uh
yeah
right on all right everybody we're gonna
go to the members only show so go to
timcast.com click join us become a
member and in a few minutes we'll have
that members only show up on the front
page smash the like button subscribe to
the channel share the share with your
friends you can follow the show at
timcastirl you can follow me personally
at Tim guest everywhere do you guys want
to shout anything out
angel.com yeah we'd love to have you be
part of stories that matter
right on he's social media any Twitter
um I'm at Jeffrey Harmon on Twitter at
Neil s Harmon n-e-a-l-s Harmon right on
people should go see that indie film
sound of Freedom I've heard it's good
yeah go watch sound of Freedom it's
still hard to get tickets in most of the
studio converted to indie film yeah yeah
that was a studio film converted Indie
and now then somehow turned into a Q on
and thing
well I'm really glad you guys were both
here uh I'm Hannah Cliff Brimley I'm a
writer for timcast.com you should follow
at timcast news on Twitter and Instagram
it's the absolute best and you can
follow me personally on Instagram at
handclear.b and on Twitter at HC brimlow
thank you so much thank you Hannah
Claire uh I'm Ian Crossland follow me on
X uh at Ian Crossland that's where I X
throughout the day and I want to just
get your your ex profiles again
it's Jeffrey Harmon Jeffrey j e f f r e
y Harmon h-a-r-m-o and Neil n-e-a-l-s
h-a-r-m-o-n got it thanks guys great to
see you man good to see you guys I see
you over there Jordan I love you brother
have a nice night everyone bye
yeah what's with making x a thing bro
it's so real you talked to Kellen about
this too they were all on it last night
so weird uh anyways you guys can find me
on Bird app which is what I'll continue
to call it uh surge.com thank you guys
pleasure you of you is my alma mater so
I appreciate you guys work and uh yeah I
will catch you later see ya we will see
you all over at timcast.com in just a
few minutes thanks for hanging out thank
you